après avoir construit les katas plus
meurtrière et des outils permettant aux
cochons de voler ce quiz est aujourd'hui
construire des pompes et chaises à deux
euros c'est ce que dit aujourd'hui au
centre en fonction bridge constructeur
va construire des [ __ ] de pont et sam
ambiance beaucoup à temps l'euro de
terre a frappé la nation insulaire de
kama tout cas et a détruit les plantes
ou des îles les pompes à les plans bla
bla bla tôt mais tu fais un scénario
alors qu'on a juste construire des ponts
ça suffit ok donc faut relier les deux
parties de la route on a un budget de
construction voilà à mon avis voilà il
suffit juste de faire ça hop voilà il a
un petit peu flexible mais ça passe bien
oui monsieur
les triangles du sont très stables
triangle isocèle où heikki latéral comme
ça par exemple comme ça c'est pas mal la
voilà vous avez vu elle est comme ça ça
tire ça tient non alors là mais quand tu
as fait un point incroyable dit pas que
ça marche pas oui monsieur n'est tenu
j'adore construire et pour vraiment
c'est une grande passion là on a des
points d'ancrage qui veut dire qu'on va
pouvoir faire quelque chose voilà la
technique des trombes d'eau sel donc qui
marchent drôlement bien et surtout un
camion au mr ouai mais j'ai bien plus de
points du coup que demande le peuple
hachez pas le faire non nulle lé convoi
de l'extrême on les fera passer par nos
ponts voilà c'est parfait non plus le
pont accordéon aller ça passe
oui ça passe bon c'est quoi au niveau du
relation client s'ennuie à nouveau
matériel aux il m'écoutait les gem
intérêts d'un hop le pont est maintenant
legrand plie en béton qui le rendent
bien dans le milieu tchèque en prêt ben
voilà monsieur mais que demande le
peuple
que demande le peuple hormis un pont pas
flexible déjà personne ne critique parce
que là il ya un pont faut juste latin
d'hockey h dépasse le budget alors là
s'il tombe c'est un scandale je suis je
suis outré mais oui sommes-nous débile
là ça tiens je m'en bats les steaks
là ça tient là ça tient lé ça tiens ça
tient tout ça ça tient ses solides à la
fin de l'ag 27000 euros pour faire ce
pont moi j'aurais donné 5 euros et saint
gobain
c'est le grand saut j'ai créé une
attraction qui sait mieux qu'un peu et
si je mets rien me voir en voilà une
excellente idée pourquoi je me faisais
chier à faire des triangles isocèle
équilatéral quoi j'ai pu comprendre de
matelas et klaxons la joie publié sur
facebook est une blague non annulé adulé
en [ __ ] mais nommée nouveaux matériels
câbles alors déjà un petit bonhomme va
pas me prendre la vie si je veux faire
un pont câble et je fais un pont câble
et c'est parti absent du coup il ya un
trou bah oui bah forcément voilà
monsieur est personnes se moquent ok
elle passe
voilà voilà voilà qu'est ce qui a cassé
le poser les câbles donc le petit
bonhomme là et avec sa salopette jaune
on n'écoute plus briguer la moitié qui
fait de l'argent ça devrait suffire à ça
ne se fait pas on s'en bat les couilles
we fuck fuck les ferrari allait au
couple dans l'eau mois et des mois à
sortir de cette secte qu'est le jeu de
création de pompe comme avant les
camions aller et voilà m
un convoi de l'extrême convoi de
l'extrême où l'arctic sea n'a pas
klaxonné
bon j'avoue il ya peut-être eu un peu
peur du coup il signera pas on va pas
faire le klaxon non plus tu vois tout
relié comme ça par des câbles est alors
dans l'esprit d'herman est passée par là
et qu'il a lui même voulu faire tenir ce
pont de bouche et n'importe quoi et que
ces [ __ ] de cabrières des 500 curieux
et allez allez ça tombe à l'eau ça tombe
ça thomas le type le mcs pub jolis airs
atterri sur les roues allez un petit mot
suivant il y retourne
il adore ça maintenant mais pas deux
fois de suite quand même s'il te plaît
elle respecte ton camarade dumas et orly
tout à n'importe quoi pop pop up en
espèrant clubs pros tiennent debout est
là tu cliques sur playa et tout tient
debout à tanger facilement n'importe
quoi mais on va voir les camions
carrément au nom il a tout dit qu'il a
[ __ ] la game il a [ __ ] la game le
conte tout se passe bien jusqu'au milieu
où la partie casse mais les voitures
s'élancent avec tellement de vitesse ça
c'est klaxons vraiment euros au suivant
il ne reste plus qu'à en change de
continent [ __ ] appréhender muté on est
propre et hop
j'ai pas le temps à s'est passé en
faisant la base de la base
messieurs dames nous sommes promus en
central mail et fait qu'elles permettent
ni ohlala j'ai mal au crâne
il nous reste 3 me de budget on s'en bat
les steaks pourrait peut-être lui
dépensé le reste du budget une petite
estrade comme ça dans le vide ça me
semble être une idée nul à chier c'était
bel et bien le nid des nuls à chier à
les jeunes camions traversent et ce pour
dans la sérénité la plus totale
ça c'est quoi c'est la victoire elle va
falloir faire incessants aux us en plan
et là qu'est ce qu'on fait on relit des
câbles et voilà on a le pont parfait
l'inertie et maîtrisé à tel point que
même les camions sur serein ce qui n'est
jamais arrivé dans l'histoire de brice
constructeur aabar hiver bah oui je sais
que tu es heureux je sais arrête ça
suffit les mots du nouveau matériel
l'acier a donc là on part que sur de la
cie finalement on peut le dire à l'est
par contre c'est bien plus cher à et
ça tient est-ce que ça tire cette
créature oui mais on n'a plus de budget
pour faire un deuxième de nouvelles
affaires en bois on a quand même pas le
budget même pour du bois quoi vous dire
à quel point celle acquise en entreprise
familiale
là on peut relier ça et ça n'aide avocat
sortie 21 boulanger vous avez rendu la
monnaie on pourrait faire ce qu'on
attendait ya certaine stabilité qui se
créent de manière totalement anarchique
oui monsieur mais voilà on apprendre c
est voir le pour un prix de son erreur
bordel vous avez tous entendu cette
chanson dans le plus tôt fait pas
semblant cette sonnerie par dompter la
version klaxons oh ça me plaît voilà du
pilier la phase était la base mais
l'extase pas tellement il ya des points
pas soutenu mais c'est par manque de
budget que ça se passe comme ça alors si
vous demandez à le réveiller vous noyer
dans d'atroces souffrances vous plaindre
et à la mairie ça passe à l' on est dans
une belle ville on doit voir beau budget
17000 très bien budget plus petit que le
désert d'avant mai on comprend qu'on
croyait radinerie est-ce que ça passe
bien sûr monsieur d'envoi les camions
allez on passe pas par quatre chemins à
un passionnant qu'un pont on n'a pas
trop le à a par contre là y'a un
problème c'est excellent une brillante
idée abri en plomb qui fera passer deux
camions à un message par ap c'est un
petit problème c'est les gars vous en
faites continuez continuez envoyer les
voitures et si ça tient pas selon malek
on s'emballe heck
et si ceux qui soutenaient le bois était
la sienne oui jamie en effet nous
pouvons constater que ton idée était
totalement nul à chier croyait france tu
peux le faire c'est comme envoyer les
voitures voire même les scooters si on
pouvait calé cette affreuse choses comme
la faut construire un immense pont et
nous disent démerdez-vous cordialement
direction ça tient sur regardez-moi ça
oui oui c'est du gâchis
il fit alors le plus petit pont du monde
de manière à ce que tout le monde s'en
aperçoit havas et le relier à tous par
des câbles parce que les câbles ça
déchire sa mère le steak lucas a fait un
pont dégueulasse certains devenir fou
littéralement la devance [ __ ] de jeu
ceci est une lettre du mec à qui vous
avez demandé construire le pont
pouvez-vous gentiment quadrupler le
[ __ ] de budget un temps il ressemblait
tellement un vrai pont et regarder ce
qui va se passer lors d'elle
j'y croyais tellement quand je vois ça
j'ai le coeur voilà mon coeur il fait
pareil je faire le 8 me demandez pas
pourquoi aller et 20000 euros le câble
non non ça peut-être sais pas mais
regardez covoiture go go go dépêche-toi
dépêche toi je t'aime et tu peux nous de
voir effectivement trouvé un équilibre
afin d'atteindre une perfection de fonds
à les voitures qui va ça passe ça passe
domaine qui a perdu tout son courage et
bien même parler et s'est arrêté à voir
voilà la petite fessée qui le fait
tomber dans l'eau quand même emballage
ainsi repassé de nos surprises
constructeur est le début on fait les
malins la fin sa part en parpaings
justement pourquoi je sais pas si vous
appelez si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas m
et vidéo moi j'aime beaucoup les jeunes
construction comme ça en ce moment je
sais pas c'est marrant ça me fait écrire
ça me fait rigoler ça me regarde et on
saute on se trouver dans une imprimerie
ça très bien ça lâche aussi fait que
j'arrive pas à casser une feuille
victimiser par une feuille a4 méga les
fêtes en famille